-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here
with Allison Williams.
Arlo, I do want to ask before
we talk about the podcast.
Is he a performer as well?
Do you sense that,
having performers as parents?
-He's a little bit
of a performer in that
he will sing occasionally.
He has a little guitar
that he likes to strum,
but he's very bossy about the
way I am during his performance.
-Interesting.
-Which I'm working very hard
to not allow hurt my feelings.
[ Laughter ]
-What does he need more of?
Yeah.
-Well, he needs less of me,
just in general.
[ Laughter ]
But kind of specifically,
so sometimes I'm allowed
to sing with him
and then other people aren't.
Sometimes I'm excluded
from singing from him,
but other people can't.
Sometimes I can't dance.
Sometimes I'm allowed
to just dance and no singing.
Sometimes I have to stay
perfectly still.
Sometimes I'm not allowed
to look at him.
-Okay.
-One might say I'm giving him
too much power.
[ Laughter ]
And that is why he will be
in therapy later.
I owe him a reason
for therapy later in life.
-Does he have a favorite song?
Does he have a go-to?
-His favorite song is "Lover"
by Taylor Swift.
-Well, a lot of...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's a really -- I can't say
I wasn't involved in that.
-They say it's a perfect song
for 2-year-olds.
-It's a perfect song for
a 2-year-old and his mom.
Another reason
to send him to therapy.
-It's like, "And then she'd make
me do 'Lover' and...
And she wouldn't look at me."
[ Laughter ]
Alright, so this podcast,
this is fascinating.
This is a true-crime podcast.
This is not a story I knew of,
but a lot of names in this,
in this story that I think
we're all aware of.
Can you tell us a little bit
about Elma Sands and the story?
-So basically the way
I was introduced to it
is a woman named Allison Flom
who created and directed
and wrote the whole thing,
said I was a tour guide
in Manhattan,
and I discovered this well,
in the basement of a store
in SoHo that was unmarked,
and I learned that it was
the site of a murder in 1799
during a pandemic.
And in that murder trial,
which was the first murder trial
with the new U.S. Constitution,
the two lawyers who were
co-counsel for the defense,
her murderer,
were Hamilton and Burr.
And so there's like -- A gasp.
[ Laughter ]
So there was -- there's a line
about it really quickly
in "Hamilton" where they say,
"Levi Weeks is innocent.
Call your first witness.
That's all you had to say."
And he is the person
that they're defending.
But there's no mention
of Elma in there.
And so this goes back
through very flawed
court transcripts from the time
trying to reconstruct the trial
with a kind of radio play,
true crime with modern language.
So it's a little bit
more accessible,
but it's just like
full of details
that are too crazy
to be believed,
like it was the first time
anyone used a stenographer.
And this stenographer was the
tutor of Philip, Hamilton's son.
So we're guessing
it's not, like, super accurate.
It has a lot of descriptions
of the prosecutor,
like being exhausted
and like haggard
and like Hamilton and Burr,
just these, like,
shining heroes of the case.
But it's really interesting
to think about,
like, this is the first trial
with a brand-new Constitution.
They could have done
some like wild, creative things,
and they just baked
all of the old systems
right into it
from the beginning.
It's just interesting
to delve back into that world
and then walk around New York
and realize that you're still
in that world.
SoHo was this area
called the Lispenard,
and there was the Manhattan well
in the middle of this meadow.
And it's just so hard
to imagine,
and it's so close
at the same time.
-Oh, it's a really cool project,
and it's always just
the best to see you.
Thank you so much
for coming back, Allison.
-Aw, thank you for having me.
-You guys, that's
Allison Williams.
"Erased: The Murder of
Elma Sands" is available
on Apple Podcasts now.
It's great.
-We'll be right back
with Fisher Stevens.